foreign
get started and as people arrive um
we'll welcome them in uh thanks so much
for joining us on this panel on on
social and environmental impact from the
center for social innovation
um today what we're going to do is have
um just a brief overview of the center
and some of our programming as well as
some of the other opportunities for
impact with the GSB
um and then we've got the great panel of
some of our mba2s that can offer you
some more insights into into some of
those programs uh so my name is Hallie I
have been with the center for about four
years and I'm so pleased to welcome you
and I look forward to sharing with you
um about this Center so I'm going to
share some slides uh which I'm going to
go through pretty quickly
um
so we'll we'll have more time for
questions uh during our panel
foreign
so um as I mentioned we'll we'll go
through some of our programs and then
um hear from our MBA 2 panel
so in general what we do is educate
insightful leaders for social and
environmental change and we do that
through understanding problems designing
and measuring impact learning how to
manage impact organizations and scale
ecosystems and we work with you to get
started on your network connections we
offer financial support and other
programming which we really won't be
getting more in your career in
one of the academic offerings that we
offer is the certificate in public
management and social Innovation this is
the only additional academic credential
you can get from the GSP
um and there are over 50 courses that
count
um toward the certificate while you're
there this slide goes into a lot of
detail and offers you some examples of
the courses that you can take to qualify
for the certificate but essentially it's
designed to help you understand problems
design and assess impact and then learn
how to build
a manage and scale organizations so the
details of it aren't really too relevant
for you right now but know that it's a
great offering that can really help you
um
get a full picture of how you want to
make it impact in the world from an
academic perspective
um just a course that I want to
highlight is designed for extreme
affordability it's an experiential
learning course that you can gain real
world practice where you partner with a
local social impact organization and we
use design thinking and you apply it to
to actually solve a real world problem
so one example of many experiential
courses offered at the TSB that that can
really help you learn
um
how to be an entrepreneur or or explore
impact in in an organizational way
uh another program I'm going to
highlight is our leadership for society
Scholars so this program allows you to
Deep dive into a societal issue of
importance that you care about and then
also it's two-pronged in that you can
also learn how to Foster
um
really contentious conversations
which you'll confront if you're working
in Impact anywhere in the world that
people will will all have a lot of
things to say and there'll be a lot of
debate and learning how to facilitate
those
um and create productive dialogue is
important
um so as you can see here these are some
of the examples of some of the projects
that students have taken on
um through the leadership for society
Scholars Elise who's featured on this
slide is here with us today so she can
share a little bit more about their
project and her experience with that but
they range every everywhere from mental
health to future of work corporate
governance
um I don't think anyone that did
something environmental is on this slide
but there were others so it's really an
opportunity to Deep dive into an issue
area of your interest
okay fellowships and financial support
um here I'm going to throw a lot of
acronyms at you uh Sif idif ecosif
um and then we'll get to
um Smith
uh lots of lots of ifs um but these are
designed to allow you to either uh
intern for an organization that might
not be able to pay you what another GSB
organization would be able to pay you
allows you to
um if allows you to really deep dive
into an entrepreneurial area of your
choice or an entrepreneurial
um problem that you're looking to solve
through through entrepreneurship sorry
um Nate is here he's going to talk to us
a little bit more about his experience
with Ida in that summer Martin
um and then for when you graduate we
also have funding and support both for
folks that are looking to join
organizations As Leaders that's our silk
prize and then folks that are looking to
be Founders and that's our stiff
fellowships and prices
um so that's that's a little further
down the road but know that we've got
these financial support offerings for
you at the GSB
um and the last thing I'll highlight in
this category is is loan forgiveness
this is
um both for for-profit impact
organizations and for non-profit impact
organizations
uh so as you are thinking about an
impact career we are well aware that
there might be some trade-offs between
impact and finance and so we have these
programs to help you really resolve that
um I'm gonna just really quickly talk
about the GSP impact fund it's one of
our experiential learning opportunities
Anisha is here she's one of our co-cios
and she can speak more about it um
during the panel but the impact fund is
designed to really primarily educate
students on the process of impact
investing while creating significant
impact from both the social and
environmental perspective as well as
generate Financial returns and when
you're a member of the impact fund you
Source investment opportunities you do
diligence on them you manage the
portfolio it's really the entire
experience so we can ask Anisha more
about that when we get to that section
okay social entrepreneurship for those
of you aspiring entrepreneurs in the
um in the room there's a lot of
opportunity to
um to explore your your the problem that
you're trying to solve
um through coaching through building
your network through the financial
support that I recommended earlier and
this next slide just sort of goes
through a lot of the offerings I'm not
going to go through every bullet on this
page but we offer workshops there are
courses
there's expert advising that you can tap
into and then of course there are
fellowships
like I said I am running through this
because we have actual students here
that can can give bring more life to to
a lot of these programming than I can
just while while talking
um okay so another important aspect of
the GSB is community
uh so I want to spend a minute just
talking about ways that that you can
grow your impact Community while you're
at the GSB
uh one offering that we have is prior to
entering the GSB you can participate in
our impact peer groups
um these are designed to give you early
exposure to what impact can be like at
the GSB by connecting with your peers by
meeting some of the faculty that are
doing research on on relevant
um impact topics and then also learn
some Frameworks that can help you
Channel your values into your career
um we also offer a lot of coaching and
Advising and these are just a range of
the the options that you can talk to us
about we're here uh I think the message
here is that we're here to support you
on your impact Journey whether you want
to talk about academics whether you want
to build your adventure whether you want
to
find other ways to incorporate impact
into your life beyond your career
another program that's actually not the
CSI program but that I want to spend
just a second talking about is the
corporations and Society initiative
um this is an organization that Fosters
conversations between
business government and Society to
um promote more accountable capitalism
and governance so
um here's some of the examples of the
the programming that they're putting on
this year
um just a really great uh example of
some of the great conversations that are
happening at the GSM all the time uh
that you'll be able to participate in
and lastly I just want to talk about the
clubs and activities this is just a
sample of some of the impact related
clubs that that are at the GSB and Nate
I know I'm missing the entrepreneurship
Club so I'll give you a chance to to
talk about that
um but these the clubs and activities
are another way to really engage with
the student Community around
um career areas of Interest or or other
areas of Interest
um and now the part we've all been
waiting for our MBA 2 panel
uh so I'm going to stop sharing
um and just take a moment and pause if
there's any any questions
uh before I before I keep going you can
always add your questions in the chat or
um
or just raise your hand
okay
so
our great panel
um
one second I'm just juggling some
computer space here
all right um I'm going to start
um at the beginning of the alphabet with
Anisha uh Anisha
is a second year MBA student at the GSB
she's co-chief investment officer of the
GSB impact fund co-president of the
social impact club and course assistant
for an impact class called Investing For
Good Anisha is passionate about linking
promising social Enterprises but the
capital they need to drive impact at
scale
this past summer she served as a
strategies and operations intern
a mission-driven fintech company that
helps renters boost their credit scores
prior to the GSB she worked at Endeavor
a global nonprofit supporting high
impact entrepreneurs and emerging and
underserved markets as well as at BCG
where she focused on clients in the
public sector
next I'm going to introduce Elise prior
to the GSB she was a founding member at
Merit America and Economic Opportunity
nonprofit she-led strategies and
Partnerships there forming Partnerships
with major employers like JP Morgan and
Amazon and developing and underwriting
the program model that has served
thousands of people
prior to that she has a map she was a
Management Consultant at Bing since
coming to the GSB she's been developing
a startup in the neurodiversity space
with the summer Fellowship from CSI and
earned turned at an early stage Women's
Health startup also with a fellowship
from CSI
um and last but not least Nate
um is an MBA 2 and an idif summer fellow
he is pursuing a career in social
entrepreneurship with a focus on helping
U.S small business owners get accessible
and affordable business guidance via
technology before Stanford networked in
strategy go to market and Technical
roles at box Inc and enterprise software
company
he also co-founded start small a pro
bono Staffing Marketplace that conducted
small business owners who needed support
digitizing their businesses
to Career transitioners looking to
validate their digital skill sets news
from Boston and graduated with the ba in
political science and communication from
DC at the GSB he's co-president of the
entrepreneurship club and at admissions
ambassador
so uh thank you for your
um uh listening to all my talking and
now I'm going to actually hear from from
some of the students who are
participating
um so the first question I have for all
of you is how have you engaged with
social and environmental impact during
your time at the GSP
and whoever wants to start can go ahead
sure I'm happy to kick it off
um yeah it's great to see everyone uh
yeah so I've had the chance to engage
with social impact to GSB in a few
different Arenas
um which Hallie had outlined earlier in
her presentation so one has been through
the classes
um another has been through sort of like
structured activity outside the
classroom and then just like largely
through the community and connecting
with other people who are passionate
about social impact so in the classes
you know as Hallie showed on her slides
there's so many different classes that
you can take around social Innovation
social and environmental impact at GSB
and I've every quarter have had a chance
to take classes
um related to that across like impact
investing and affordable housing in
California systems thinking and social
change so a whole range of different
topics and also just like different
Frameworks and skills that I feel like I
can apply you know post GSB in my career
um so that's one aspect the other is
through a structured um sort of uh
activity extracurricular outside of the
classroom which for me has been the GSB
impact fund which is a student-led
impact investing fund
and each year we invest in early stage
companies that are creating positive
social and environmental impact and so
we have a team
um that is focused on supporting our
existing companies that we've invested
in and helping them grow and then a team
that's focused on sourcing new companies
and so going out to meet Founders
diligencing their companies and then
bringing those forward to our investment
committee which is comprised of faculty
and Senior impact investing
practitioners so that's been a really
incredible experience
um you know getting to to learn the nuts
and bolts of impact investing through
through trainings and then actually
getting to apply them in the real world
sort of through hands-on experience and
working with with Founders and getting
to see that impact really come to life
um and then finally in the community it
this just happens all the time at GSB
you know meeting people through classes
through clubs through activities you
know CSI staff who just like provide a
lot of advice mentorship
around social impact and that's been
really
enriching for me as well
thanks
I'm glad Anisha went first because she
had a great three-part framework there
um a good former consultant
um I guess if I touch on the same
buckets starting with academics yeah
I've definitely enjoyed some of my
courses and um I think some that stand
out are Freedom democracy and capitalism
um with Keith Hennessey just really
interesting discussions and now just in
a kind of broad like survey class of
impact called impact ID to Enterprise so
that's really interesting and then in
terms of the outside of the classroom
stuff I think anything at CSI that has
some acronym I'm doing it or I've done
it um so I did idif over the summer
um with Nate which was I loved like
cannot recommend that enough
um just the time to like really
explore an idea I I had but hadn't had
the chance to really
um dig into and so continuing on with
that now
um also for part of my summer I did
Smith which is
um a program that Holly mentioned around
um
you know just it's just extra stipend
for your summer for organizations that
can't pay you Market rates so interned
at a women's health startup
um and then
L for us leadership for society
um where the two components are last
year did just research around a topic I
care about and then now I'm doing the
dialogue facilitation which I suppose I
didn't think I was excited about but I
actually think I'm more excited about it
now
um than than the first part
um I mean we just had our first dialogue
this week but I think that's going to be
a really cool experience
um and then on the community aspect
um yeah I think like Anisha said like I
think it's just a really nice Community
one I I love both Anisha and Nate
um but I also think like
um I remember like at the beat near the
start of MBA one year I went to a
session about this certificate that
Hallie mentioned and you know there was
like an hour blocked for it but it only
took 15-20 minutes to be honest and then
so it was over but then everyone just
stayed you know for the rest of the hour
and was hanging out and talking and so I
don't know I just thought that was very
indicative of the community
you all hit on most of the the things I
would point out but maybe just a few
other different areas to focus on from
an entrepreneurial lens I would say
um you know when I first got to campus I
was overwhelmed with how to spend my
time with all that there is to do and I
met with a uh an advisor from the CSI
focused on entrepreneurship
um and that helped me sort of put my
ducks in a row and and really get
started with my journey so I couldn't
recognize recommend the advisors enough
for that and once I started going down
that path I
um did a lot of different things on the
academic front
um in in addition to classes I did a
what's called a 390 which is an
independent study
um not particularly run through the CSI
but um that independent study allowed me
to sort of start on that social
entrepreneurship journey by doing some
significant research and I pulled on the
people that I had met at the CSI to help
make connections to make that process
easier
um I also did it this summer once yeah
what's cooler than getting paid to be an
entrepreneur
um and then
um
I also continued with the same idea
through startup garage once again not a
CSI
um program but start garage is an
experiential entrepreneurship class
where you you go and build a team and a
business and there is a social impact
lens that you can take and framework
that you you go through if you do
consider your business social impact so
I've done that
um with the hopes of you know getting
the credit necessary for that
certificate that Holly had mentioned
um yeah I think those would be sort of
just a few other areas that hadn't yet
been covered
Dave um how was your thinking changed
about your engagement with impact uh
during your time at the GST
I can start because
um
at the as as one of the co-presidents of
the entrepreneurship club and for what
it's worth when we say we're like
co-presidents of something it's not that
cool there's nine of there's nine of me
there's nine co-presidents it's what we
do at in business school to inflate
everyone's title
um but the uh what I've found to be
really interesting is that impact just
means something different to everybody
and there's no right or wrong definition
I myself am interested in building a
for-profit organization that has a
really important mission that helps an
underserved population but I do want to
make money and uh I think that you know
it's been interesting sort of sitting on
the entrepreneurship club uh Team where
everybody's talking crypto and I don't
know what have you
um and hearing their perspective of what
impact must must mean right like oh Nate
you must want to go and start um you
know some really really awesome but uh
you know some awesome non-profit
somewhere but that's just not for me so
it's been really interesting having that
dialogue with folks and getting it like
trying to bridge that Gap
um since we're all in it you know we're
all really interested in solving really
cool problems
um just from different angles so that's
been something that stuck out to me
um yeah I was gonna say I mean maybe
not quite as big a transformation as
innate there
um I think
my thinking has evolved more around just
the specific topic
um and content
um I think in my application essay I
wrote about things around like diversity
and Equity
um and I mean I still think that's
important by all means
um but I'm just kind of
honed in on like a more specific area
um in the neurodiversity space and like
my leadership for society project last
year was different than my idif project
and then
um you know found that like I really
want to keep pursuing my idif topic um
and the leadership for society staff was
also really helpful with that
um in kind of being able to put the
resources from leadership for society
around this new topic even though it
wasn't what I had been doing last year
so yeah just more Evolution around
specific topic
and then for me I think my sort of
Engagement with social mediation how my
thinking evolved over my time at GSB was
related more to my career path so at GSB
a lot of people talk about you know
coming into gsv wanting to like test a
career hypothesis and for me I knew I
wanted to work in social impact but I
needed to figure out like where and so
that boiled down to me for either
working
um on the funding side or the operating
side
um so either like investing funding and
amazing entrepreneurs like Elisa Nate or
actually like working at companies
um that entrepreneurs are starting and
so that's what I used as my framework to
like figure out what types of things I
wanted to do at GSB
um which meant like during the year I
did impact fund and then over the summer
worked at a startup
um that is uh Mission driven startup and
that helped me figure out like having
those different experiences helped me
figure out that I want to be on the
funding side financing side of social
impact
um so it helped me like narrow down
where I want to be and and I've realized
I want to be at like the earlier stages
of of funding and so yeah that's how my
journey with social impact has evolved
what I'm gonna let
um let our uh admit with our hand raised
whose name I am not going to pronounce
follow me
um thank you thanks so much please ask
away
I'm sorry I didn't see there was
anything in chat but I'm really excited
to be here and sorry for joining late
I'm Salome I'm from Ukraine and the
question I have is I currently have a
social impact platform that I have done
for Ukraine and with um Center for
social Innovation but also with my MBA
journey in particular I really hope to
scale all the processes that I have
there and really continue to build this
platform
um Beyond Ukraine as well but also
create something meaningful on a kind of
that will impact more people than it
impacts right now the question I have
what are the resources that are helping
um social innovators to scale and to
prepare for a larger landscape and if
there are any uh could you speak on your
experience with them or recommendations
that I should follow
I can start and then I'm sure maybe this
might be an interesting question for
Hallie or Matt to also speak on um
I guess I'll take it from just a general
Stanford Legend because to be honest
with you the way I think of the CSI what
makes it so special is it like connects
so beautifully to the probably better
than most uh organizations at Stanford
to everything else that's available to
you
um so there's a a program uh within
Stanford called The Venture Studio
community and that is where you get
access to resources that like are like
discounted software for like Amazon web
service credits or you know you know
whatever you might need that Community
also has is it's um not only current
students but also alumni that are you
know having conversations about hey like
what um you know what lawyer would you
recommend for this or something like
that while at Stanford though you do get
access to free legal services so that's
another thing that you can use to keep
up with it so I'd say the Venture Studio
Community is huge one thing I've really
loved is that
um the CSI also has uh gosh I'm gonna
get the name wrong but like rotating
fellows or advisors who come in from
with industry uh experience they're like
currently running some really cool
social uh impact organization and you
can speak with them about some of the
specific areas of your of your
challenges interest what what have you
um and get some great advice on a
recurring basis so just a few things
um that are top of mind for me please
Anisha I don't know does anything else
stick out to you before I don't know if
Haley or Matt has something either
yeah I mean scaling stealing your
Enterprise that's actually not I'll let
you I'll let you take this one and I
should have introduced this as Matt Nash
he is the director of the center for
social Innovation to Welcome Matt yeah
and and scaling is an obsession of mine
I was at uh Duke University for 18 years
before I came here and a lot of our
research uh was on scale and we created
several accelerators and so forth so you
got me going but what I would say is you
know in the case uh such as yourself um
I would highly recommend you engage in
our social entrepreneurship program as
Nate was just saying we have both a
group of visiting social entrepreneurs
who are experienced including some
alumni who have launched and scaled
ventures of their own and also an
amazing group of what we call our social
entrepreneurship expert advisors who are
a variety of practitioners and these
folks come from a wide variety of fields
and areas that could advise you and then
there are ways to take advantage of our
programming like a idif could be some
summer money to kind of explore maybe a
scaling hypothesis that you have or some
of our courses might help Steve Davis's
class on scaling might help you think of
new Pathways that you might want to
consider or you know other programs like
that so absolutely so it'd be a mix of
kind of customized and I think Nate also
makes a really good point that there are
lots of other resources at the school at
the University level as well that you
might want to tap into so I guess my
bottom line recommendation is sign up
for one of the team the CSI team
advising appointments early on and we
can help Orient you for that for that
path
thank you so much and kind of going off
of that do you know if we are allowed to
reach out like during summer or before
we matriculate essentially like before
September would that be okay or should
we wait until December yeah how you
mentioned peer groups
so the peer groups is really sort of our
first point of things
and that's an opportunity to to both
sort of get
a sense of your peers as well as CSI and
they'll start to build that relationship
um and we're still sort of starting out
the timeline for our summer programming
so more to come on that
all right um do we have other questions
from some of the folks in the room
all right I'll let you think on your
questions for for another minute and ask
women in the interim
um this much about electives and and
what you found most helpful in in
um
you've mentioned it you've mentioned
some of your coursework in your intros
um but you know is there a course that
you found really supportive in helping
you explore your interest or or
otherwise and it might not be an impact
course I think this is sometimes some
something that's surprising to students
that are interested in the impact they
find some of them are more traditional
coursework
um just as as interesting as some of the
impact coursework and and that's to say
that there's there's an opportunity to
really get a whole experience while
you're you're at the GSB so any
electives you guys want to highlight
yeah I think honestly most of my
electives last quarter were great they
were all very soft skill focused very
like I was in what we call touchy-feely
but interpersonal Dynamics
and was in a course called managing
growing and well I technically stated
but seeing isn't that hard um
it a course called managing growing
Enterprises
um which is just kind of about like all
of the difficult conversations you have
in a growing org
um was in like a strategic comps class
so I really loved all of those because
well one like I I did study business in
undergrad but I think at that point in
time like it's just much more like
tactical like Core Concepts and you're
not like you haven't experienced some of
these like difficult conversations so
one I just like felt in a good place now
you know compared to undergrad to really
be thinking about these things
um
and to
it it just feels really relevant um like
even though it's not like every case in
managing growing Enterprises is like in
an industry I'm passionate about but the
issues that came up like I still think
will come up in the in this in the the
topic spaces I care about and so it just
felt like
I know just like a really
thought-provoking
um situations that that will certainly
be challenging and maybe I'm you know a
little bit better prepared to face them
now
at least on that I was uh just just I
guess maybe a fun anecdote that I'm
currently in um startup garage with
doing an experimental experiential
entrepreneurship and I swear I am now
like thinking of myself as being inside
a case uh for managing growing
Enterprises yesterday I had to have a
tough conversation with a teammate I had
to tell an engineer that he didn't get
the role on our team I had to uh tell a
customer that we weren't moving forward
with her on a pilot you know so I'm
having all these really tough
conversations and so that stuff has been
so helpful one other class I'll just
point out that falls under the um social
impact
um like certificate accounts for this
for that for that certificate is a class
called fiscal policy with Keith
Hennessey and I'm not like thinking that
my area of impact and focus will be in
the fiscal policy space but Keith um was
the was a former economic advisor to
President George Bush and he made me
just understand
the gravity of decision making and
public service
um in such a way that like I I don't
know I just read the news differently
and I think about
um what it means to be in a high level
uh government role differently and maybe
even like got a little more interested
in in doing something
um in government at some point so uh
really make sure you take a class with
King Tennessee uh before you before
2025.
uh one class in particular that I really
loved was Investing For Good Very
related to my career interests and
impact investing and it's taught by
um two real world impact investors
um who come in and are able to kind of
share their experiences but yeah the
classes uh really interesting because it
covers impact investing across asset
classes so a lot of people when they
think impact investing think like VC
like impact VC but in this class you're
exposed to what does impact look like in
public markets what does it look like in
like sort of debt what does it look like
in like real assets like real estate and
so that was really cool to think about
impact financing across all these
different asset classes
um and yeah you you learn these very
practical
Frameworks in these class in in this
class and then you have the chance to
apply them because we do these like
simulations where we evaluate deals and
and Pitch them and bring them forward to
an investment committee that's comprised
of us the students in the class and so
um yeah it was it was very like
practical Hands-On learning it didn't
feel like I was learning this like sort
of like theory that you know I wouldn't
know how to actually apply in real life
so that was a really great class
all right thanks
um
again I'll just pause for for questions
from from the folks in the room
and shy group okay
um here's one that that might be on the
minds of our advents uh in the room how
did you choose to spend
um to focus your time in the first year
there's
so many things that you can do with the
GSP so how did you choose to focus your
time and what might you have done
differently in hindsight
uh I don't know I'm just laughing
because like it's so hard to like
um like
I don't know I think and I think this is
true like at any MBA program
there there's just so many things
happening all the time and so
you know it's something right you make
some decisions and sometimes it's hard
to know like were they the right one so
I think honestly like
I'm just kind of ever evolving in how I
try to think about this
um
I think you know as I think about first
year to now and this isn't related to
social impact per state but I think like
you know my first year I spent more time
than I am now at like bigger just social
things
um and now you know trying to prioritize
my time a little bit better and actually
work on my Venture and those types of
things so it's just one of those things
that's like always in progress if I'm
being honest
yeah definitely no like magic formula
um for how to do that I think for me
what really helped in my first year was
to go to go deep on one thing because
like your first year you can feel like
you're just getting pulled in so many
different directions there's so many
different things you can try and it's
like all this like wide breadth of
activities and
um for me to help to have like a
grounding to like really go deep in one
area which
um for me was the impact fund and that
was a pretty significant commitment as
well and I felt you know being able to
really commit a lot of time to that I
was able to get a lot out of it in terms
of
um spending a lot of time with other
people who are interested in in impact
and getting to that every week like
through our team meetings and
um you know outside of that like I'm
actually getting to talk to
entrepreneurs we're innovating the space
and like dedicating time for for those
calls and
um those sessions and so
yeah I loved being able to like really
focus on on that amidst like the flurry
of all the other
um activities and and things that are
available
um one thing I I wish I did more in my
first year was connecting with alumni
um I didn't prioritize that as much in
in the first year because you know I was
so excited to like connect with with
other students and and with everything
happening on campus but alumni are like
such a treasure Trove of like wisdom and
experience and insights as well and so
if I could go back in time to my first
year that's something I would probably
do differently
Anisha I think you hit on something
that's super important which is
um and like I say this to a lot of
people as an admissions Ambassador as
well as like you really need to come in
with a thesis a hypothesis that you want
to either prove or disprove because of
the fact that there's just so much going
on once you arrive on campus the classic
example I'll give is at noon a lot of
the programming happens because it's
during lunch there are no classes and
you'll have to choose between going and
seeing a really impressive speaker who's
done X and another impressive speaker
that's two doors down that's done why
and so
um focus is important
um and so I came in you know with a
hypothesis of a of an area I wanted to
focus on and I'd written my essay on it
and so I kind of just said okay like it
was good enough for to get me in here I
might as well just like go down that
path and it's been a fun uh journey to
explore it
um so I I would just really recommend
heavily to just find something that you
wanna you wanna test out
um and I think that there are a lot of
folks at CSI who can help you refine
that statement along the way
um
so then what would I do differently gosh
you know one thing that uh sticks out to
me is I didn't take across the street
classes
um across the street classes are just
the term we use for any of the school
other than the GSB at Stanford it's a
huge
um plus that you can join those
um but I think I just got too
overwhelmed I always wanted to take
something in public policy at the law
school but there's so much going on
um in our own course load and then I
kind of think
if I'm not taking a class I should be
working on my Venture and so it's just
hard to
it's hard to dedicate the time necessary
to do that but I would really recommend
you try to take advantage of that
yeah I just want to add like a plus one
to that that's something I would do
differently it's really incredible to be
at Stanford at GSB because there's
obviously so much that is within the GSB
Community but like thinking about the
broader Stanford Community we have all
of these incredible schools across like
engineering law policy education
um and Stanford is I feel like very like
cross-disciplinary and it's approach to
like social Innovation and and social
and environmental impact and so getting
access to all of those classes and
students across all these different
schools is really it's a really cool
opportunity
um like I'm taking one this quarter that
I absolutely love an across the street
class on um affordable housing in
California and it's hosted by the urban
studies Department
um and I'm learning so much and there's
a whole host of different students in
that class so just want to like
emphasize or add to but um Nate shared
about that
same
definitely take across the street
classes I was in a great education class
around Behavior design
um last year and now as I'm building my
MVP for for my my Venture
um just thinking a lot back to those
concepts of how do I create this like
Tech enabled tool to help people manage
their condition but
they have to engage with it and you know
be excited to do that so
you are thinking of starting a adventure
is that something you're thinking about
oh I knew there were a few of you in the
room okay great
um let's let's take a minute and talk
about that
um so for
um Elise and me
um
you know were you thinking of starting a
venture when you came to the GSB and
um you know I know you both did either
but
um what what are some of the most useful
resources you you found in helping you
um develop your Ventures
um I was thinking of starting something
but I was a little bit like either I'll
start something or I'll join something
like really early stage
um like I just knew I liked
entrepreneurship and that kind of
Scrappy environment
um because the org I was out previously
I joined when it was I always say it's
the fact it was the founder in a
two-page word doc of her idea
um
and so I just like knew I really liked
that type of work but wasn't sure like
should I do my own thing
um and
I guess like a couple things that helped
clarify this for me one is like honestly
that it was a application was a great
forcing function for me
um to be like okay you know I kind of
wrote about this idea in my application
and then I did my leadership for Society
on this topic you know and thinking that
through like if I have like a real
dedicated time like what would I be
kicking myself for for like not
exploring
um and Grace said CSI was also very
helpful um in thinking through that with
me as I prepared for my ideas
application
um so that was um I I would say pretty
like
um important for me and then
the other thing that I think is
important for me is just kind of the
culture at the GSB in terms of
recruiting or maybe lack thereof um like
I came from an underground environment
that was very recruiting on campus
recruiting heavy if you didn't have your
job by October senior year people were
like what are you doing
um and
I think the GSB in some ways is an
outlier among MBA programs
um in that
I mean certainly some people recruit for
for more traditional careers but
there really isn't that pressure too and
so I think it gives me a lot of freedom
and flexibility to feel like
I might as well try to do my own thing
if it doesn't work
then I'll get another job after and you
know even the people in the class above
me I remember seeing them post on
LinkedIn after like starting a job in
October then and they only started
looking in September or August because
they decided
you know they traveled or they got
married that summer or something so just
kind of that lack of pressure on
traditional recruiting I think just
creates a lot of freedom in like how I
feel around being able to pursue
entrepreneurship
uh on a more tactical note
um one thing that I think everyone
should know about because I didn't know
about it until like maybe later than I'd
like there is money uh there's impact
fun uh impact funding it's like two
small grants right it's called impact
small grant funding it's like two
thousand dollars up to two thousand
dollars a quarter that you can apply for
um and that is the difference between
you know like can you get your website
up or can you you know can you test out
your MVP
um so look out for the money when it
comes your way
um
in addition to that I think yeah I think
um hearing from those who have done it
successfully is is is what's best and so
some of the classes we've talked about
excuse me another one I'll point out is
formation of new Ventures I'm currently
in that and it just Chronicles
GSB grads who started their own company
and it even explains like well what was
their process like while they were at
the GSB
um so that was really helpful as well
and then yeah experiential
entrepreneurship
um so being able to take a course where
you have to apply and go through that
process
um and then like build a team around it
it's the best way to see will it sink or
swim
awesome well thank you guys
um just you know want to pause again for
some more questions from from the folks
in the room
yeah please go ahead uh visit saman
uh it's Simon hey thank you thank you so
much for the session it's it's really
really helpful uh so I just had a
question I'm an international student
and I understand that you can't work in
your first year but you could volunteer
with an international organization uh so
I had two questions around that a you
know if you know somebody who's done it
or if you've done it you know what have
you been your thoughts about it and the
second is how would you recommend going
about that process of you know finding
an organization to volunteer for you
know in your first year
I can start by answering the second part
of what I'd recommend
um I this the summer before I came to
the GSB I
um decided to volunteer on uh coveted
vaccine distribution oh did I freeze no
I'm good on coven vaccine distribution
um internationally and I just used my
Stanford email and sent out a bunch of
cold emails and it worked
um so really leverage that Stanford
email address you'd be surprised with
how many people want smart free support
so I don't have an answer to your first
question but I'm almost certain that
using that email address will help you
yeah I I mean I'm not International but
um something that comes to mind is last
year I think during winter quarter I
didn't part-time internship with Tech
Stars like the the
um accelerator program and
they bring on they I think there were
maybe five of us in my class who
did that internship with two of them
were International
um
and so unfortunately they couldn't get
paid which was
obviously not as ideal as getting paid
um
but you know for them they were like you
know this is still like an interesting
learning experience
um
and they probably did like a slightly
fewer hours per week than those of us
were getting paid because you know
um and then one of them in her summer
actually continued part-time like she
had a Maine summer internship and then
was still doing like five or ten hours a
week
um for Tech Stars because at that point
she could get paid
um and so it was kind of like the school
year apart was an investment for her and
then to then get paid later
um but also like
so many there's so many part-time
internships that get sent around at the
GSB on slack on like the listserv all of
that and so the you know they're not
called volunteer opportunities but they
could be if you just unfortunately can't
get paid
thank you so much maybe I'll jump in too
I mean there are another there are a
number of other kind of um slightly more
formalized programs the uh Seed
Accelerator at uh GSB works with small
medium Enterprises all around the world
we have something called g mix that
makes short I think minimum four-week
experiences available but but also this
would be a great opportunity to plug
into CSI because we have an incredible
network of alumni social entrepreneurs
and social Ventures there are also a few
other networks out there project Redwood
project Redwood is GSB alumni who are
identifying social entrepreneurs around
the world and supporting them and so
forth so I would say plug in with us and
then I'm at the risk of of looking dumb
in front of everybody Hallie do you know
have we ever run into issues with uh
International students participating in
Smith I I guess it would be news to me
no I I believe International students
are eligible for Smith are eligible
right yes right so so so maybe don't
take that statement with uh I mean talk
with us because there may be other ways
I mean my understanding is there are
some opportunities for this sorry the
Smith is the um where you're interning
with a impact-based organization I'm
getting sucked into the alphabet soup
myself these days uh and um uh you know
there are opportunities to
take that in a way that inhale again
correct me if I'm wrong here at the risk
of it but there are ways to maybe apply
that toward tuition rather than taking
it as direct income I may be wrong about
that but anyways I guess the bottom line
is definitely talk with us and with um
financial aid
um and the CMC to figure out
opportunities that would work for you
okay thank you thank you so much
all right other questions
quiet group
um you might be joining us from
um odd times across the world
um we recognize that
um so I want to thank you all for
joining us
um
if if there are another no other
questions
um Lisa I think you have a quick pull
for us
um
you could just take a second and fill it
out
um
we'd love to hear from you we want to
make sure we're
we're meeting your needs and I just want
to thank our panelists Nate Elise and
Anisha
um we're sharing some some great wisdom
with our with our students
and we we look forward to seeing you all
on campus
um so thanks so much everyone
thank you
[Music]